[MUSIC PLAYING]
FERNANDA VIEGAS: I have a lot
of stuff to show you today.
I'm going to show
you some live demos.
Living dangerously, but
that's the way I like it.
And I thought I would
start by telling you
a little bit about who I
am and where I come from.
As [? Annalee ?] said, I co-lead
a research team here at Google.
And our mandate is to do data
visualization for end users,
so turning very complex data
into really interesting images
that people hopefully
can understand
without too much hand-holding,
making complex data
very legible and digestible.
And you know, I work at
Google, but the truth
is I am a very
unlikely technologist.
Nothing in my past
would ever tell you
that I would end up
here, or doing what I do.
As [? Annalee ?] said,
that's where I come from.
I grew up in Rio.
Ended up coming to Kansas.
I did not know about the
flat lands in the US,
or anything like that.
But I loved it anyway.
And my background is graphic
design and art history,
very traditional graphic
design and art history.
I had never, ever
touched programming ever
in my entire life.
I had no interest
in it, actually.
I loved things that were visual.
So this was like a poster I
did, and a book cover I did.
But then when I was
about to graduate,
I decided I love visual things,
but it started feeling a little
limiting for me.
And so that's when I
learned about a place
called the Media Lab,
where they welcomed people
with different backgrounds.
And so that's when I started
thinking, oh, maybe I
should start picking up
programming, this thing
that people talk about.
And so anyway, ended up doing
a lot of data visualization.
And data visualization
is nothing more
than turning data
like this, raw data,
into pictures that hopefully
tell stories and bring together
so many numbers in a
way that your mind,
that you work with your
visual system to digest.
This is what data
visualization used to be.
So when I started
in the field, this
is what visualization
used to be.
It was very scientific, and it
was very, very male-dominated.
And it was sort of like serious
technology for serious people,
you know?
Only experts.
Also because it was hard.
It was expensive to be able
to run graphics of any kind.
Thankfully, this is very
different now, right?
So now, you have all
sorts of different kinds
of visualization projects.
You have visualizations
that are artistic.
that are journalistic.
You have entire reports that are
done through data visualization
and infographics.
You have visualization
being used for activism.
And I am very
interested in this arc,
in this change that goes from a
very sort of serious discipline
that's very limited to
something that becomes more
of a mainstream communication
media welcoming people
to the world of data.
That's one of the things that I
love about data visualization,
is that it can be sort of
like a gateway to statistics,
like a gateway drug
to statistics, right?
You're doing statistics
without having
to have a degree, without having
to learn about distributions
and such.
So I'm going to
start by showing you
one of my favorite projects.
And this was done before
I even came to Google.
So it's called the web seer.
And-- oh, and one little note.
All the work I'm going
to show here today,
it's work that I
didn't do by myself.
It's work that I did with my
partner, Martin Wattenberg.
We've been working together
for, like, 10 years.
And so when you hear
we, that's what I mean,
it's me and Martin.
And my team also.
But this was done
way before Google.
Before we joined Google.
We started noticing that the
Google Instant, right, you
start typing things
into Google, and it
starts giving you suggestions.
Any clue about why
Google does that?
Why does Google give
you suggestions?
AUDIENCE: So you have a
better search [INAUDIBLE].
FERNANDA VIEGAS: So you have
a better search experience,
because it's faster, because,
you know, maybe this way
you don't have to waste
time typing everything.
And these suggestions are
the most popular things,
the most popular
queries that people
have come to Google with given
the beginning of your string.
So if you say why, well,
these are the things
that people usually
ask Google about why.
So I want to actually do
one little thing here.
I'm going to show
you a visualization
of the same kind of data.
So now, I'm going to say why.
And I'm visualizing
the same data, OK?
But I'm going to
say why doesn't he.
And you can see that I'm
showing the same information
that Google is showing you,
but I'm also showing you
a sense of priorities.
OK, so why doesn't he like
me is the top thing that
comes after why doesn't he.
But now I want to
do another thing.
I want to combine that
query with another one.
I want to compare and
say why doesn't she.
And now the visualization
is showing me
where these two come together,
and where they break apart,
right?
So why doesn't he or she
love me or like me or text
me first is interesting.
But why doesn't she just
leave is only for shes.
So you know, you start to get
a sense of interesting things.
And you can play with this.
This is a public visualization.
You can play with this.
You know, is chocolate--
chocolate-- versus is coffee.
And you can start
to see what people
are worried about, right?
But then you can get
to more serious things,
like is my son versus
is my daughter.
And you can-- you get a sense
of people's vulnerabilities,
right, of parents
coming to Google
and actually asking
these questions.
And this is something
that I love about data,
is that data can be seen as
something so cold and removed,
but when you look at a
picture like this, it's not.
It's like, oh my god.
It just hits you, right?
The good news is that if you
turn that from a question--
is my son versus is my
daughter-- to an affirmative--
my son is versus
my daughter is--
the best and awesome is
still some of the top things
you get there.
So again, this is
just to give you
a sense of the kind
of visualization
I'm interested in.
I'm interested in visualization
that resonates culturally
with people, and sort of takes
you out of that notion of,
oh, you know, data
is something boring.
I want to show you
another visualization.
This is something that
we did here at Google.
And this is a map, a real-time
map of the top viral YouTube
videos in the US right now.
And I'm showing you
what-- and it's by region.
So let's look at Boston.
This is a region for Boston and
Manchester in New Hampshire.
So this, you know,
do it yourself
ORBEEZ SLIME video is the
top one that people care
about right now in our region.
But the top one is
this video game one.
I'm going to break it down
by interesting demographics.
So let's look at what
males are looking at.
Oh, this is 13- to
17-year-olds, OK?
All right.
It's going to get better.
I promise.
So males are looking at this.
Female youngsters are
looking at the ones
that the Bostonians
like the most.
But as I go over
older demographics,
it changes completely, right?
So this is what older ladies are
looking at, "Little Big Shots"
Sassy Viral Dancer video.
And males are all looking
at this Trump supporter
punching a protester
in the face.
There's other things,
too, that are very local.
So like this video
here about flooding.
Another one also about flooding.
Very local.
So this map changes every day.
It's live data.
And you can see things that
sweep the nation, which
is really interesting to me.
So let me just go back
to my presentation
here, and let me do this.
OK.
So I just wanted
to call attention
to a couple of
historical screenshots.
So this was last year,
or a year and a half
ago, I forget, when males were
looking at the "Men of Steel"
movie trailer.
And then-- whoops-- and
then females on the same day
were looking at the Dove
"Real Beauty" commercial.
Does anyone-- has
anyone seen that?
Yeah.
Yeah, right?
Me, too.
When this was happening,
I was like, oh yeah,
I'm part of the demographic.
Yeah, I get it.
Yeah, that's true.
And then you have things like
these, that you can't make up.
Grandma smoking weed
for the first time.
And it just, like, sweeps
the country, right?
And it's awesome.
I watched the video.
But one of the
things that was cool
is to actually see that not only
cat videos go viral on YouTube.
That was a relief.
OK.
Let me talk about a different
kind of-- in a sense,
both visualizations I
showed you to this point
were sort of real time-ish.
The Google Instant
is an aggregate.
The YouTube is real-time.
This is a very different
kind of visualization.
A few years ago, Martin
and I were approached
by the "Boston Magazine."
And they said to
us, can you create
a visualization of Boston
for us on the print magazine?
So it was non-interactive.
We love doing things
that are interactive.
So this is even
more challenging.
How do you visualize an entire
city on a piece of paper?
So we started
thinking about Boston.
And one of the
things that struck
us is the seasonality, right?
OK, great.
How do you get
that through data?
So we decided to go to
Flickr and look at-- scrape
all the public pictures
of the Boston Common
that were licensed under the
Creative Commons license.
And we scraped that for
an entire year's worth.
So we had photos for
January, for February,
for an entire year of the park.
And then what we
did is we started
counting the number of pixels
that were different colors.
So for the bin of January,
how much white is there?
How much red?
How much blue?
OK?
So this is just a color cube.
And this is how we
divided the color cube.
And basically, by counting the
pixels, some of these cubes
became bigger, some of
these cubes got smaller.
And then we decided
we would sort of
have this over a whole
year, and overlay
each hue on top of each other.
And then we decided,
because it's a yearly thing,
it's a cyclic thing, we decided
to put it on a circular format.
And this is what a whole
year of Boston Common
ended up looking like.
So at the bottom
here, this is January.
And you can see that
on the Boston Common,
there's a lot of snow, right?
As you start getting
closer to spring here,
you get this fuchsia layer.
And this is a lot of the flowers
that are blooming in the park.
You get this bulge of greens
here for beginning of summer.
And then it flows into sort
of like more towards the fall
foliage over here.
So this was our way
of trying to capture
a year's worth of Boston through
looking at the Boston Common.
We were very happy because,
since we were working with data
that wasn't ours, right, we
were just scraping from the web,
it's very noisy data.
People don't go to
the Boston Common
just to take pictures
of the foliage.
They take pictures of their
kids, or of the carousel,
or of the frog pond, whatever.
And so it was
totally unknown to us
whether we would
have any signal that
would tell the story that we
were interested in in terms
of seasons.
And if you broke
this very flowy thing
into the different
seasons, you can
see that the
distribution of colors
is actually dramatically
different between summer
and winter and so forth.
OK.
And then I want to finish
with one project that
is very interesting to us.
So before the awful
winter we had last year,
there was another
winter that was not
nearly as mild as this one.
I'm so happy about this winter.
And so Martin and I were
thinking, you know, weather,
is there anything we
can do with weather?
And we decided there's a lot
of-- there are tons of data
about wind, about weather.
Is there anything
interesting we can do?
Well, the truth is,
wind has been visualized
for hundreds of years, right?
And so these are sort of
traditional visualizations
of the wind.
And they tended to be static
and sort of like vector
field-based, right?
And so you do get a
sense of direction.
You do, by the
length of each arrow,
you do get a sense of speed.
But still, it's hard to
get a gestalt, right,
to get an overview and
sort of like, oh yeah,
this is where there's a little
round thing going over here.
This is where there's a
major pattern and so forth.
So we decided to play
with this idea of,
even though wind has been
visualized for hundreds
of years, is there anything we
can do that's new on the web,
and that is more
dynamic or feels more
like this movement of the wind?
And so let me show you
what we ended up doing.
So this is the wind map.
It's a live visualization of
the wind over the US right now.
And it's public, and
it's always there.
And by keeping a
lot of the detail,
by not averaging everything
out into a vector field,
and keeping animation, you
do get a much more texture
sense of the wind, and how
there are these broad strokes
in the middle of the country.
But then, how over here in the
West, even though we're not
showing you anything
about the way the land is,
you can still see the tracery
of the mountains there.
And then you can start to
play with this and zoom in.
And you can see here Boston.
And we're doing great, because
we're not having too much wind.
And wind is coming
from the south
up, which is awesome,
because it makes
for that nice warm weather.
But then another thing
that was interesting to us
is just how much the
wind changes day to day.
So we ended up creating
a small gallery
of different days of wind.
And so you get things
like this, where
this is a day where, like,
Canada was stealing our air,
and not even the mountains
were stopping them.
And this is very unusual.
This is a very
different kind of day.
You also have days
like these, where
there's a lot of stuff
going on in different parts
of the country.
And you just-- you know,
it's like the wind parts
in different ways, sort
of how you part your hair
different days.
And then you have
stuff like this,
where you start zooming in
and this is Hurricane Isaac
making landfall.
And because this is a
real-time visualization,
this was running,
and we were starting
to get emails from people.
Like I remember this
one person said,
I live here in New
Orleans, and I'm
looking at your
visualization, and I'm just
praying that this thing just
stops, just blows over us
and we're OK.
And that was a really
powerful moment,
because we had never
had a visualization that
was real-time, where
seeing this felt so--
made us connect to people in
different parts of the country.
It wasn't until we had this guy
that we realized what it meant.
So this was Sandy
also making landfall.
And for this-- you know, for the
first time we were in the path.
And so this was interesting
because it was a visualization
that sort of could be scary.
We had never had this
situation before.
And so I want to tell you a
little bit about the reaction
that we got for
this visualization.
Oh, yeah, and the other thing
that-- just because that's
my-- that's what I
do, I visualize data,
one of the things that I
think is really interesting
is the data on these images
is exactly the same data as
on these images, right?
And so the way in which
you approach something
makes a big difference.
One of the things that
we're not doing here,
that we're trying,
striving to do here,
is to show as much detail
of the data as possible,
to not aggregate the
data as much as possible.
And that has a
bunch of pitfalls,
because it could create a much
more complex visualization
than people can understand.
But in a fascinating
way, I would
say that the complexity,
the visual complexity
of these pictures here,
actually helps your eyes.
It's sort of like when you have
more pixels in your camera,
it just, like, focuses.
To me, it's sort
of the same thing.
It's like, oh finally, I can
see these broad patterns of wind
that, actually now, seeing them
all at once makes sense to me.
So we started getting
a lot of email.
A lot.
Like, we have never gotten
this much email before.
And so it turns
out that farmers--
we did this as an art piece.
We just put it on
the web, and we
thought it was going to be this
completely sort of niche thing.
It was like, who cares
about wind, right?
I didn't before I did
this visualization.
But it turns out a
ton of people do.
So farmers will look
at this visualization
before spraying their crops.
Scientists will look
at the visualization
for bird migration, for
butterfly migration.
Teachers love to
show this to kids,
and to try to sit with them and
try to think about forecasts,
weather forecasts
and is this a week
that's prone to tornadoes,
and things like that.
Pilots started looking at this
visualization before flying.
And then when we started-- both
commercial and military pilots,
by the way.
And so when we got those
emails about the pilots,
we're like, whoa,
whoa, no, no, no.
Do not look at this map
before you fly your plane.
We very specifically say that
we are showing surface wind,
right?
So surface wind is from the
earth to, like, 10 meters.
It's like, you're going to
fly your plane way above that.
And that's not going
to be the wind.
They know that.
But it just got a little
bit too scary for us.
Like, wildfire firefighters
would look at the visualization
before deciding
on their strategy.
And so something that started
as our curiosity about the wind
ended up being a
utilitarian tool for people
without us knowing.
And it is great.
At the same time, you feel
like you're on the hook,
because what if your
visualization isn't right?
So we put a disclaimer.
We said, do not use this
map for flying a plane,
sailing a boat, or
fight wildfires,
because we got multiple emails
about each one of those things.
And we thought, OK, just
FYI, we have this disclaimer.
Then we started getting
emails where they're like,
we understand that
it's your thing,
but respect the power
of the visualization.
And so this just, to me, is
a really interesting moment,
because what it tells
me is that we are coming
in an interesting
other end of the arc
I was talking to
you about before.
When I started
working in this field,
we were very much in the this
is scientific, for scientists
only, for experts only.
And now, I am so
proud that we have
ways of talking about
data, of looking at data
where we're embracing so many
more communities, where it's
not about whether
you're doing science
or not, or whether about you're
running a government or not,
but it is about
your life, right?
It's how you
appropriate the data.
How do you make use of it?
How do you become a better
consumer, a more skeptical
consumer of data?
And so that's what excites
me about this kind of work.
It's sort of like how can
we use these powers, right?
How can we use data for our
own benefits as citizens,
and become better at it?
And I think visualization can
play an awesome role there.
So that's it.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
SPEAKER: Thank you so much.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
We're going to
have a few minutes
here for questions and answers.
We have a couple runners
with speaker-- with little--
what are they called?
Microphones.
Thank you.
So, yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very much.
I just had a quick question.
When you started--
no, I'm sorry,
I wanted to ask both of you.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You
started off your talk
about talking about diversity,
and how that Google,
you know, embraces
it and everything.
I have read over, I think,
the last year or so,
I guess, some not
very good statistics
about diversity in
high-tech companies,
and how that women
make up only, like,
5% of the engineers at all
these high-tech companies.
I just wanted to know if you
could talk about sort of where
Google stands in that,
and is Google any better
or worse than your compatriots?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Hi, [? Annalee ?].
Hi, Fernanda.
Sorry to steal that.
I just wanted to
take that because I'm
one of the members of
the diversity team here.
So thank you for that question.
It's super important.
For those of you who
don't know or may not
have seen it, around
this time last year,
Google released
our public numbers
around diversity, gender,
and I believe also
some ethnicity numbers.
So I would say reference
that for the most up-to-date
statistical information.
And I believe we will
be refreshing that
around the same time this year.
So you guys can be
looking out for that.
Until that
information comes out,
we can't talk specifically
about the actual numbers.
But if you have questions
about last year's numbers--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Oh.
I would just say, for all those
details, check out the website.
The reports are all there,
and they're much more
elaborate than I
could be right now.
I would say, for this
Q&A, if we could just
focus it on Fernanda's content.
And if you have other
diversity questions,
just feel free to let us know.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: My name
is [? Anya. ?] I
just wanted to ask you,
Fernanda, about your work
particularly.
You mentioned about
visualizations and statistics,
and I was wondering,
from my knowledge of it,
how do you deal with-- because
with visualizations, you
can show powerful information,
but you can also mislead,
because there are outliers,
there is a section
sample of overall big picture.
I was just wondering how do you
deal with that in your work?
What are the strategies
that you try to make
sure that the final
product avoids
the potential misleading?
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Yeah.
So it's true-- so visualization,
as with any other media,
you can mislead with words,
you can mislead with pictures,
and you can mislead
with visualization.
So we try hard to make sure
that we have checks and balances
for whatever data we work with.
And there are different
levels at which we do that.
So for instance, we
have user studies,
where we show things
to people and we
try to understand from
their perspective what
are they getting from the
representation we chose.
I'll give you a very
specific example.
I didn't show this
project today,
but we have
launched-- last year,
we launched with Google
Sheets the ability
to automatically
visualize your data.
So when you open
Google Sheets now,
if we identify a data
table, we'll automatically
visualize it and verbalize
things about your data,
verbalization
meaning we will say
things that are of
interest about your data.
So we started
saying things like,
oh, this is growing
exponentially, by 2%.
And then we realized that lay
users do not understand that.
What do you mean, an
exponential growth of 2%?
An exponential growth is
an explosive growth, right?
So we had to reword things
because our jargon was not
making sense to end users.
I would say another thing
that we did a long time ago,
we created-- this
was not at Google,
this was when I was at IBM.
We created the
first website where
anyone could come
upload data and create
interactive visualizations
of their data and share
with others.
And when we presented that at
the top academic conference
on visualization, on
data visualization,
it was a half and half split.
Some people were really excited
about the ability of giving--
of making this technology
available to end users,
to anyone without training, and
half of the people were like,
are you crazy?
How dare you put these
visualization techniques
in the hands of non-experts.
They're going to mislead.
They're going to come up
with the wrong conclusions.
They're going to visualize
the data in the wrong way.
To which I say, let them.
Because if we don't make
these tools available,
then people are
not going to learn.
I want people to make
little mistakes with data,
play with things, before they
make big mistakes with data
at government or at industry.
I want to have a pipeline where
kids-- so in this website, kids
were playing with data, right?
And that's the kind
of pipeline that I
think is important for you to
grow as a consumer of data,
as a consumer of
data visualization.
You have to become more skilled.
And the only way
to become skilled--
I think one of the
most effective ways
is to play with it
yourself, right?
So yes, I'm sure people
will make mistakes.
But I welcome them,
right, before they
become big mistakes.
Like, I want little mistakes.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Your presentation is
incredible, by the way.
And you come from a very
creative background,
it seems like.
And you've made this
transition to sort
of like cutting-edge
data analytics.
What advice do you
have for someone
who wants to make the
same type of transition,
and perhaps what obstacles did
you have to surmount, if any,
sort of coming
from one background
and going into another, but
staying true to what you love,
it's just in a
different context?
So can you talk about your
journey and your obstacles?
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Yeah.
So as I said, I had
never programmed before.
Like, I programmed very, very
little before I got to MIT.
So I will give you-- so yes,
there were lots of hurdles,
and it was hard.
So I think one of
the things that
helped me was hoping that I
was going to learn this stuff,
and believing that I could.
But I remember being in this
one software engineering class
at MIT and just, like,
crying my eyes out
because I was just like,
I am the dumbest person
in this entire class, in
this entire institute.
I'm never going to get this.
And then just working and
working on it on-- and until I
got-- until programming
started to sink a little bit.
I think the most
important thing is
being open, and understanding
that getting out
of your comfort zone
is hard, but it's OK.
I feel like I never
grew as much as when
I went from graphic
design to the Media Lab,
where I was exposed to all these
intellectual tools I had never
been exposed to before, and
all these different ways
of thinking.
It's hard work, and it-- and
in my case, it hurt a lot.
Maybe other people are just,
like, more naturally prone to,
you know, going from visual
to very mathematical thinking.
But it's worth it.
I feel like it was
the best thing,
was to have these two very
different perspectives,
and just finding that
connections are where
the excitement is, really.
I think there's a question
all the way there.
AUDIENCE: For someone who's
interested in learning more
about making data
visualizations,
are there specific tools
or libraries or things
that you should learn
about to move forward?
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Yes.
There are some really nice tools
and communities at this point.
So one, I-- two
things I recommend.
One is the processing community.
There's processing.js.
And there's a very
strong community there.
And people are happy
to answer questions.
And just the community
aspect is great.
If you already know a little
bit of front-end programming
and you just want
to go, oh, what
is visualization
libraries, then I
would say D3 is the way to go.
It's not super welcoming
of newbies, I guess,
but the good thing about
D3, I would say this,
is they have an amazing
set of examples.
And so you can just
reuse the code.
You don't have to start from
scratch, which is awesome.
And D3 is what everybody
like the pros use.
So it's great.
AUDIENCE: So just asking
more library questions.
Where do you think WebGL
is trending in the future,
and what do you think are the
late-- the sort of hottest
libraries, whether it's
three.js or, you know,
something that is a little
less mature than D3?
FERNANDA VIEGAS: OK.
So are you specifically
interested in 3D things, or--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
and what libraries
do you think are really
sort of hot at the moment?
FERNANDA VIEGAS: OK.
So I would say definitely
D-- oh my god, now I'm
getting all confused in
my library names here.
One of the things for me is
that I do a lot of 2D work.
So even WebGL, I'm just now
getting started with WebGL.
And one of the things
I'll say about WebGL
is that I'm actually
starting to learn it
so I can do 2D things with it.
And I think that is a
really interesting-- oh, OK.
All right.
That's a really interesting next
step for these 3D libraries,
is to how can we co-opt
them for 2D work?
And so what is-- you
mentioned-- is it js-- three.js?
Yes, that's one that
I would definitely--
that's one of the ones
we're exploring with,
and we've had the biggest sort
of return on investment so far.
So I would definitely
look into that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]